on this episode we talk snapchat
discover disrespect in meetings and how
to convert on your website
[Music]
this is
Carrie be everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 170 of
the askgaryvee show
I am fired up this Monday morning
because my New York Jets defeated many
other people's New York Giants I was at
the game I was super pumped and we we
stole it late which is always a nice
feeling I was already settling into a
devastating week of anger and upsetness
and instead it was flipped as only
sports can do at the last second and I
was very happy indeed did you kind of
pay attention to what was going on were
you do you rock you were watching
because you were obviously we're
shooting the dailyvee today and you
wanted to see what kind of atonement
Stefan did you give a crap you did and
you watched her nice thanks some in a
good mood we also continue the new
concept of having a veiner medium did
you dress up for this no I have a
holiday ready respect why don't you tell
the Vayner nation who you are how long
you been here a little bit about
yourself a minute yeah so my name is
Matt um associate executive I've been in
just under two years flies yeah yeah
going well yeah where are you from what
else what are you into besides brushing
a banner okay I don't respect you but
let's keep moving
I'm just working on a whole bunch of
teams got some tough sicko like going on
how's that how's a New York life good I
was right everyone's good here yeah I
man I love having you here bell rings um
India I think you know we've been
outside I mean it's been a while since
we've been in our kind of like our home
field to do our show
I think we should start the show okay
well let's get into the show go with me
yeah so long we're so attitude all right
let's get focused Maria oh by the way
before we get into the show I want to
thank everybody the enormous amount of
feedback for daily VOA one was
tremendous
d-roc we enjoy that right we like
gathering feedback and we're taping oo2
right now filming oh - and I feel like I
feel like we've got some tricks up our
sleeve do you rock and so I'm excited to
see it what do you think will be out
tomorrow awesome can't wait all right
Andy let's do this Mariah asks do you
think too many brands are on snapchat
discover does each edit brand decrease
the value for others I think I think
each added brand does decrease value for
the others because it's simple supply
and demand when you go there and I mean
when there was 18 apps on day 1 or 800
or 53 or whatever was on day 1 of the
app store you know that was good for
those apps they had more attention when
there was 3 channels on TV back in the
day
that was good for those channels when it
was 13 for quite a while it was good for
those channels and then you had cable
and they were 36 for a good while and
that was good for those channels and
then we got into DirecTV and a thousand
and we got the Internet of course
everything is important for supply and
demand when you've got a bigger
percentage of the attention now so it's
not as good for the apps or the media
companies behind them but it's better
for potentially better for the user and
snapchat and that's why it's happening
right if you go on snapchat discover
back in the day and there's all these
brands and you don't give a rat's ass of
any of them well it's not as valuable to
you but as it starts bringing kind of
new things to the equation new
subcultures niches things that you're
into you'll be excited and so you know I
think that um I think for snapchat and
for users as long as the channels
continue to expand and bring value to
people it's like the internet the
Internet's better than cable television
because it gives more people more
options of consuming what they want then
one will counter argue that well then
there's just a bunch more crap there was
plenty of crap when I was 13 channels
was crappy check snapchat have what like
eight or nine six channels when they
launched did you love all of them did
you know I mean so like this notion that
limitations cure a better stuff is a
very arrogant POV from the people that
have vested interest in saying small
because they're getting more value
I like the capitalism and this and the
real meritocracy so I love the Internet
I love that you watch or listen to this
show because you really like or I'm
bringing you value because there's a
shitload of options it's not because
it's 1957 and I'm one of the three
anchor men that evening you know when
there's like a couple of other options
I love the supply and demand of the
Internet of the open web of the maturity
of where we are and so I like that for
the end consumer I like that everybody
that's watching and listening right now
has unlimited options and they can find
what brings them value and so to answer
the question directly yet it's not as
good for the media properties but that
doesn't matter because snapchats job is
to make it better for their users and
for themselves
EJ Chapman asks my podcast website gets
a lot of pageviews but they're not
translating to listens what can I do to
help conversion well I mean there's a
lot of things you could be doing DJ one
you'd need to be thinking about how you
get them in there and two need to think
about what happens when they get there
Allah let's go old-school let's make
pretend that your pods are are a
restaurant okay you open a restaurant
and you've thousands of people coming to
your restaurant but they're not ordering
food they're just sitting there and
they're not bringing you any value
there's a couple things to debate one
did you bring the right people there if
your marketing was come to this
restaurant something amazing is gonna
happen that you've never seen before we
can't tell you it's a big surprise you
might win a million dollars
then they all start showing up they
weren't there to eat your burger they
weren't there to eat your fries they
weren't there to eat your salad they
weren't there to drink a cup of coffee
they were there because you made a
promise that when you got into the
restaurant I'm treating your place as a
diner by the way in my brain
you know you didn't deliver that they're
like cool pickles and coleslaw but I
can't because like I thought that we
were gonna get a million dollars there's
that or there's another thing they came
and when they got there they didn't they
into the restaurant and there is no
there's nobody in the front to guide
them to their seat there's no maitre d
or welcome person they walked in it and
it's like an empty warehouse with weird
signs and they're just confused to where
to go sit and where to go eat I'm
painting you a picture because there's
two fundamental things that happen when
you have this problem this is for all of
you either you didn't make the right
promise to get them there and when they
got there they were disappointed or not
interested or it was the wrong reason
and the only thing you were trying to
make happen was get everybody there you
didn't think about the part that
mattered which was get them to order
food or when they got there because they
wanted to be there they didn't
understand how to execute on the
transaction so that means your marketing
stinks and you're not telling a proper
story of getting them in or your UI and
UX or promise or landing page
optimization or directions to do once
they're there or there is this you makes
me think about how is it optimized for
mobile
maybe maybe Mobile's bad it also makes
me thinking this is more of the kind of
problem that the marketing that you're
doing or the PR or whatever you're doing
to get people there it's predicated on
getting them there not to do the action
that you want or number three they're
getting a very quick sample and there's
hearing or seeing you somewhere else and
they just don't like you like there's
always number three which is you go to
the restaurant you sat down you knew is
gonna be a burger joint you got there
there's somebody that set you down you
ordered a burger you ate the burden
you're like yeah not that good of a
burger India like just fine or more
likely for so many people that are
watching here like good burger but I'm
not gonna go 15 blocks I got a burger
over here next to me and so you know
like there's burger one block away you
know which might you you're not a burger
you know but you know but like you know
there's burger here and I don't want to
go there and so that's another thing
that the friction convenience is such
king right they may have somebody else's
app already downloaded or they already
have two other podcasts downloaded and
there's no one about they don't even
want to take the second to download
another one they they as a person back
to contradiction of the first question
not contradiction different look at it
is they don't want more supply of
content so the guy I already got Gary me
and I've already got James out sure I
already got Ferris or I've already got
you know school grants or I already like
I don't need another one that's the same
so you're not differentiating those
real business lesson that was a really
good question to answer
I really hope people watch that thrice
cool is right Spears ok ok good
Britney asks how do you personally take
charge in a meeting when you feel others
are being disrespectful
I guess Britney's asking for herself and
for everybody who's listening for me I
mean I just get involved I mean the
first of all I mean 99% in time the
context of the meeting I have the
leverage either I its my meeting end or
you know I have a lot of authority or
street cred to open my mouth is the one
more time how do you take charge when
you think somebody else is being
disrespected yeah no I see this all the
time and I see people struggling with it
especially if they're middle management
or the new kid on the block or the
intern but they have the EQ or the
empathy and they're like oh this is
unfortunate and you know I would say
that you know there's only two ways to
live life to two tactfully address
things or to eat it and have regrets
that you didn't address it what's the
name again Britney Britney you know I
think that you have choices here look
you know if I was in a meeting with this
crew and I was being disrespectful to
Stefan
and India felt like she wanted to say
something what's running through her
mind is if I call Gary out here you know
first of all she has a lot of context on
me so she's probably thinking oh crap
it's the Fonz doing something wrong but
I don't know about cuz carries usually
right but let's say I was tone-deaf and
I didn't have equity with her and it was
her first week you know she's thinking
that if she calls me and says Gary why
are you doing then you're being rude
she's thinking oh crap that could get me
fired and then like what does it mean to
me like like people are doing practical
verse there's always the pressure of
doing the right thing versus the
practical thing and then you're always
questioning are you good enough to know
what the right thing is you know there's
all that stuff you know I don't know I
have had a very successful life
forget about career on being comfortable
of addressing things in real time in the
room if it needs to my level of thinking
of disrespect is quite high because I
like combativeness and
Pettit eveness and and I've also always
had leverage I work for myself so my
advice to myself or like how I think
about the world is very different than
the advice I'd give to a lot of people I
think you go with the one strike policy
India should grab me or send me an email
after that meeting and say hey I thought
the hair uncomfortable with the way that
you were treating Stefan in that meeting
can we either talk about it she'd grab
me in person she could send an email I
like in person cuz no context is lost
because if I got that email from India
oh my god like that's a little prima
donna for a youngster like she doesn't
know all the details but if she told it
to me I'd be able to feel the energy
that's one lesson I'd like a lot of you
to learn setting a text or setting an
email where's it's an important moment
you're losing so much context the energy
especially if you go to an EQ person the
energy is so powerful when you can
create the context so I highly recommend
that but I would probably go with a
communication it wasn't confrontational
in the room with that manager or that
boss the first time behind the scenes
lightweight treading water and then a
seeing how they respond because I would
respond and we've been there and done
that India I would respond favorably
which would make you more comfortable
and safe to talk to me again others be
like China now that would making not as
much comfort and then I would address it
in the room the second time if I said
shave came out to India and then she did
it again the second time a couple things
would happen she'd feel like she was
getting that off her chest more
importantly I'd be like damn she really
does care about this you know just life
like doing the right thing is always the
right thing you just got to make sure
you're doing the right thing way too
many people romantically want to fight
against the system fight against the
boss fight against the company and I've
had people in this organization that
have barked up the wrong tree because
they've worked in other places where the
person doesn't give a crap and doesn't
turn every stone and doesn't have a ton
of context that is something you need to
be careful of do not walk into a buzzsaw
because you do have a manager or a boss
that actually knows what they're talking
about
now if you're great at EQ and the tone
and the taste roll let it roll but this
is not a very simple question there's a
lot of angles as you could see in two
quick seconds that I've given you here
it's a lot of context building who you
standing up for I mean the amount of
times the people here have stood up for
somebody who's straight losing
like doing the wrong thing but they're
homies that I mean that you know let's
talk to you because they hear it from
this look we we have a tremendous
culture here where we're obviously I'd
like to say that but how many friends do
you have in this company like people you
actually hang out with outside of work
it's all about give me a number
are you funny great so first of all
everybody who have banners watching this
is now wondering wait a min my number 21
and what the hell I thought 15 or 20 I
think anybody who's watching we would
all recognize that's a big number
there's a lot of people watching here
who dimed a single friend that's why
everybody just if you not if when your
friend one of those 15 or 20 complains
about Vayner it's impossible for you not
to take their side they're your friends
I mean that's an impossible game and I
assume I'm asking you now you know it's
even though you like me and think I'm a
good guy and it's a good company good
culture
it's so much easier to be to have
Janet's back than the companies that
right there is the issue at hand right
you might be standing up for somebody
you want have you ever wanted to stand
up for somebody yeah have you right and
so it's just tough because you don't
know every I mean I know a lot of the
friend pods in this company I knew to
ask that question because I knew it was
a good outcome because I I know what's
going on here right even people that are
a little quiet or or what-have-you like
are finding front of me it's amazing
right we got a good thing going the the
danger of that is blind support to your
homies versus what's going on in the
office there are people here who are the
greatest human I literally want to adopt
them I literally want to adopt them hey
come in my family I love you that much
who are average workers that's just real
life [ __ ] to think of I was there homie
outside of work and had all the feelings
of the humanity that is them which is
remarkable I want to adopt them and to
think about them complaining or struggle
why didn't I get promoted my boss is not
taking care of me this and any other
thing it's impossible for the other 550
people here intermingled with each other
not to support that person they're the
best but I have the optics of another
thing which is the black and white not
the warm and fuzzy the do you have the
skill I'm great
sky of all-time I don't think LeBron
wants me on his basketball team I do not
have the raw skills to provide him value
for what he's trying to achieve
I'm the mask and if you want to do
business I'll make them more money than
he can even realize even more than he
makes which is more than he can realize
and that's the game and so that's the
other part of the equation you're gonna
step up for the greatest person of all
time cool you just might get caught
because they're actually below average
or not doing a good job or they may
actually act differently I mean this is
happening here too there are people that
outside of these four walls I want to
adopt but when you watch them how they
act with in a work environment they're
just okay a lot of sweeties and then a
little Sparky or manipulative in
political in the building that's just
real life so know who you're standing up
for interesting [ __ ] yeah it got very
deep you know that's something we can
all learn from I've learned that lesson
like I know this guy is the greatest I'm
like wait a minute he sucks in the store
like I saw with my own friends that work
for me
so anyway it is intense its intense
because it's so this is where judging
where you work or who you work for is
the key like you know and understand
what they're good and bad at meaning you
could have a great manager top top
manager and they might be strong at X
but they may be out of Y and if they're
bad at why you need to be you need to
context that there's no blanket
statement even on the person I'm a lot
of points of view on your strengths or
weaknesses from a lot of different
people way more than you'd ever think in
a good way meaning like it's just like
it's it's why we're so calculated here
of what we do cuz we don't take the main
boss's point of view on somebody it's
360 its contemporaries its friends
outside of work it's people they've
never heard of them it's people that
work for you you can't just be like oh
the boss if you let that they'll just
manipulate what's in their best interest
because this human it's not their fault
but I think that's what makes our place
tick because people have seen very
senior people not win the battle against
very junior people and then that's like
whoa and that's cool so I don't know how
I got on that tangent I know how it's if
you want to step up for somebody in the
room you better know all the scores the
conversation skills
all the people involved all of it you
should comment about rating sama tired
here from the happy healthy human I'm
curious what's the psychology behind why
people are on periscope I saw your
interview with marie forleo recently
where you talked about the psychology of
why people are on pinterest and twitter
so why periscope no great question oh
thanks hon you're welcome Samantha like
the hunt
I think the psychology on that is I
think you know it's live TV right and
there's some people that are good at QVC
or Saturday Night Live I was got a lot
of kick out of like as I started meeting
famous people I heard a ongoing
conversation of the actors and actresses
that would not do Curb Your Enthusiasm
because it was not structured enough
they were scared of the improv nature or
SML and of course you know that spoke to
me because I think I can crush those
things but if you if there was cue cards
right now I can't read or spell or
Lambie like and today on the ask Gary
Vee show like you know I'd be weird so
I'm always fascinated by people's
strengths and weaknesses I think
periscope is great for people that can
improv just roll keep it saying and I
think people want to you know want to
project themselves I think everybody's
fascinated with television and and
getting out there and so if you're doing
periscope you're somebody who doesn't
fully take themselves seriously and or
you're very confident in your improv and
your truths
the reason I'm super into doing dailyvee
and things of that nature is I'm not
scared how it's gonna be edited the only
reason I'm even involved in editing is
sensitive information of like clients
and stuff of that nature but like
clearly like the bald spot thing I'll
talk about anything like I'm willing
it's so crazy I think I might lose
another 15 pounds and gave me a couple
more muscles like I'm getting close to
just living like naked don't do that
okay terrible reaction but like that's
like where I'm willing like like it's
quick you understand let's use make it
as a metaphor yes I'll probably not walk
around naked though it's crossed my mind
um living life pretty naked and by the
way I'm not naive like we've all got
skeletons there's plenty of things that
I don't share you guys all know I don't
share my family like there's a lot but
boy I like pushing myself further and
further because it is literally the last
battle of a mile when you take ownership
of all your flaws and weaknesses
you've won and I actually think that's
the Nirvana
of the connected world yes privacy's
getting pushed on yes there'll be
negatives but boy there's a lot of
positives with us all putting our
laundry to each other we get accepted
it's no different than high school to
college the difference guys this is so
basic the difference between high school
in college and why everybody likes cut
not everybody but a lot of people like
college more is you've matured into a
place where you can own your [ __ ] more
you're sensitive to your zips and your
reader thing there's a lot of weird [ __ ]
that happens between 14 and 18 we change
a lot and like we're not ready to
calibrate that and it takes very far and
few between people that can own it all
the way we're insecure our security is
much stronger in our 20s that it is in
our teens and that's why we like it
better Adam asks I feel like I've lost
my hustle help what do I do
Adam anybody who's losing their hustle
has a lot of variables and there's a lot
of variables in this episode this is the
variable episodes where's a lot of
context but it's not just direct answers
today um listen you might have you might
not be passionate about your North Star
anymore I I've been going through
something let me actually break some
shattering news here for the first time
in my life I've been thinking about
weird things like sabbaticals and
building a business school in Haiti for
five years and like like I love listen
I'm still all about buying the New York
Jets and it's the process of that and
the game but it's amazing for me to be
in tune with myself the maturity like as
you get older like just step like my
kids are six and three and they're
interesting like it's inch they're
interesting and like you start you know
I start projecting what do they look
like at 13 and 15 like if you're really
cool to like I don't believe in the
school system as much as everybody like
do I just take them and go do something
rogue like just different things like
you just evolved and and you might have
just lost your North Star the thing that
you thought you were going for might not
be it's why it was always happy that I
didn't want a million bucks or I didn't
want Fame or I didn't want a car private
plane or these little things like it was
fun to be like I want to buy the Jets
and what that always meant to me is I
want the process of buying the Jets
which means I get the hustle forever
because that's my that's who I am maybe
you've lost who you are or what you want
or maybe you've accomplished kind of or
maybe you feel it's achievable I would
be crushed if I thought what I wanted to
achieve was super achievable I mean it
happened to me in the wine business is
happening at Boehner like as Vayner is
becoming a player in the agency world
and we're not like that now we're like
oh like and soon we're gonna be like oh
like you know like like that's not as
fun for me I like being the underdog
I like the climb you know I like that so
maybe that's happened maybe you're just
tired I mean I think one of the things
that the New York Jets do for me that
nobody understands is those hours
actually you just caught something on
dailyvee right me talking Jeff that was
the first time I talk business during a
Jets game in 15 years I looked at my
phones at wrong time it was a very big
thing and only spent a second on it like
I am escaped and relaxed and by the way
I didn't care about it like that's how
excited like those three four hours of
escapism maybe need some vacation time I
maybe you need to look at the people
around you maybe you need a change maybe
you need to break up with your boyfriend
or girlfriend like there's like there's
a lot of intense different things that
can be happening or maybe you can take a
step back and really listen to this
statement which is you've lost your
hustle because you've really are not in
tune to why you're doing it right you're
just not in tune to what you're doing it
that that that you're maturing and
realizing like a Ferrari or a fad watch
or courtside tickets or custom Mike's I
just wanted to show them you know isn't
that what you're living for and so you
know it's funny tonight I'm going to the
charity water gala I never thought of
myself ten years ago somebody who would
be so involved in nonprofits sitting on
the border pencils of promise donating I
was you know I was old school in 40 I'm
older like this this new narrative of
much better people and that's what I
think you guys all are I think you're
much better generation I grew up
thinking I'll get rich and when I'm old
I'll be like giving out money and doing
that stuff so you just evolved right and
so maybe maybe you like me like I
haven't gone completely like I don't
have enough money like my kids can give
away all the money but I can't I don't
have that luxury yet
but maybe you want to do nonprofit maybe
you want to build schools for pencils of
promise and we'll take you and Laos like
maybe you've lost your purpose so take a
good step back shut down shut down for
24 48 72 hours go away go away like this
this is how I want you to shut down go
to Airbnb this is a 2016
way to shut down go to Airbnb find a
very remote place you know taught you
have to go I'm sleeping sup yeah I'm
just wrapping up the show sorry
go to go to Airbnb find a very remote
place that's you can get to at a low
cost like a crappy cabin far away on a
four-hour drive where you can like just
drive because you can or like somebody
will drive you there or like hitchhike I
don't give a crap lowest cost farthest
away seclusion and just be with yourself
and start talking to yourself for real
for like really talk to yourself a real
one of the great things I do with myself
is I talk to myself for real you know
really nobody is a harsher critic and a
bigger fan of themselves than me and I
think that friction in both directions
matters yeah that was interesting I've
never said that before I've never said
that before yeah yeah because because
yeah
just hasn't come up but like like I'm
into it like I I want to take a
one-month vacation like I really do I
really really do I really like I'm
smitten you know what else is happening
I love this time of year I love when the
rest of the world doesn't work because
then I don't feel guilty that I'm not
and this is a great time of year you got
Thanksgiving for a week then you have
two weeks that are completely shut down
and very honestly nobody loves the
hustle more than me on earth I'm
massively excited for two weeks from now
all that family time Liz and I are going
away for four days just her and I
because Panem Peter watching the kids as
parents so that is like like I'm living
for that you know cool good show you
brought out the good stuff question of
the day if if I told you to go away for
72 hours and be with yourself where
would you go yeah what would you do and
make sure you watch tomorrow's dailyvee
I'm excited about this do you rock I
think we're up to something you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
them
oh there is one other thing I'm gonna be
making a wine video an ad hoc little
thing for Instagram or Facebook about
this wine I made called the competitor
perfect name it is the 1999 Cabernet of
the season check it out I know a lot of
your buying gifts and party stuff I want
to make sure you guys know about this
put together like a $45 cab
for 20 bucks I'm excited about it but
you're looking at later just want to me
I know more people watch this so we want
to make sure they know about it see you
later
[Music]